pas bonjour à toutes et à tous et
bienvenue pour ce nouveau l'anatomie
comparée pour les nuls cette fois avec
des crânes mystérieux et non pas des
crânes d'alien et non pas des crânes de
nasca je vous rassure c'est pas encore
une énième vidéo à propos des crânes de
nasca on a fait le tour du sujet on a
déjà fait plein de vidéos je voulais
remet dans la description si jamais vous
êtes nouveau sur la chaîne et que vous
avez envie de savoir mais non on ne va
pas reparler des craintes de nasca
l'affairé régler l'affairé résolue
j'ai déjà dit tout ce que j'avais à dire
sur le sujet et les vidéos sont en ligne
sur le site d'hier n'a donc je vous
mettrai le lien vers le site d'irna si
vous voulez savoir ce que je pense des
momies menace cas et en plus j'en ai
reparlé la dernière fois dans le débat
une cage et pénitence sur les dinosaures
intelligent parce que même quand je
parle de dinosaures intelligent on me
ressort les crânes de nascar donc voilà
la fin de la vidéo des dinosaures
intelligent et encore à propos des
crânes de nasca donc il y en a marre
voilà enfin des momies menace qu'a donc
non il y en a marre on ne reviendra pas
sur les mots me menace qu'a donc il y
aura que du crâne mystérieux pas
forcément du crâne d'alien voilà mais
que des crânes qu'on a du mal à
identifier
et puis ce cette petite vidéo en fait je
vais la tournée un peu bas comme un tuto
voilà c'est un tuto pour nos amis
ufologues et arqués oman ou pyramide you
si vous préférez appelé les arcs et oman
des pyramides you c'est un tuto sur
comment économiser son argent donc
comment économiser l'argent des analyses
adn comment économiser l'argent de
radiographie inutile comment économiser
l'argent de datation au carbone 14
extrêmement coûteuses et inutiles
voilà c'est si vous voulez c'est un tuto
amical quoi c'est pour vous dire ben
voilà il existe des réponses faciles à
des questions de crâne mystérieux et
justes en connaissant ses réponses et
bien vous n'aurez pas besoin de faire
toutes ces analyses extrêmement coûteuse
il suffit d'écouter les bons
scientifiques et puis surtout quand vous
demandez des analyses adn ou des
radiographies ou bien des analyses
carbone 14 va vous demander finalement à
quelqu'un en blouse blanche de vous
confirmer que brosse c'est pas humain ou
bien à séparer sans donc
évidemment vous allez entendre que
quelque chose n'est pas humain n'est pas
récent qu'est ce que vous allez en
conclure que c'est un ancien astronaute
non pas forcément pas forcément si vous
avez un échantillon qui n'est pas humain
il reste encore 3 millions d'espèces à
exclure avant de commencer à envisager
l'hypothèse extraterrestre ou ancien
astronaute ou whatever donc
et pareil pour les analyses ad pas
pareil pour l'analyse carbone 14 si ça
vous donne le résultat que séparés samba
ça veut juste dire que ces anciens ça
veut pas forcément dire que c est ôtée
ricains donc voilà faut pas non plus
prendre les gens qui vont vous donner
les résultats de ces analyses comme des
experts est allé dire comme c'est le cas
de ce magnifique site que je m'en vais
vous montrer
voilà le grand changement le grand
changement c'est maintenant voilà allez
dire comme ces gens là l'ont déclaré en
janvier 2016 qu' il y a des crânes que
la science ne peut pas et ne veut pas
expliquer parce que théorie du complot
ça aurait remué des théories officielles
en question voilà les finalement
quelqu'un qui en blouse blanche et qui
vous a fait des analyses ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'ils les experts ça
veut juste dire qu'il est capable de
faire les analyses et on peut pas juste
parce que ces gens là ne sont pas
capables de vous répondre déclaré des
choses du genre on ne peut pas et on ne
veut pas expliqué voilà moi je suis
scientifique
je peux vous expliquer et en plus j'en
ai envie donc aujourd'hui je m'en vais
vous expliquer des cas de crâne
mystérieux qui sont soit disant
inexpliquée et surtout inexplicable
c'est pas un des bunkers j pénitence
donc je vais pas présenté que la page
web de ce site mais je vais juste aller
vite fait à travers ce site pour vous
montrer ce qui ce qu'il ya dedans est ce
qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui donc les
crânes de paracas c'est typiquement un
truc qu'on va pas aborder aujourd'hui
parce que les crânes au blond comme ça
on en a déjà parlé un million de fois et
c'est pas intéressant c'est c'est déjà
connu donc dans la catégorie on veut pas
et on peut pas sas a qualifié absolument
pas à cette catégorie
donc en l'occurrence il suffit d'écrire
dans la barre de recherche google crâne
au blond explication scientifique
voilà le mystère des crânes blanc du
pérou est enfin résolu journal du geek
et on tombe sur un site qui a le bon
goût de nous expliquer de nous donner
l'explication scientifique de la façon
dont les crânes oblong été fait donc ils
citent un article relayé par
l'université de cornes de cornell et
paru dans la très sérieuse revue je cite
cure en anthropologie cure entre
d'anthropologie qui est une très
sérieuse revue est donc bien il nous
explique que finalement les crânes de
nouveaux nés
c'est écrit ici été modelé grâce à une
armature en bois et des tissus en cuir
voilà ça m'a encore une fois pris
littéralement 30 secondes pour trouver
une explication scientifique la preuve
que les scientifiques veulent et peuvent
expliquer les les crânes de baraka donc
et en plus je il parle directement des
crânes de paracas en question donc je
suis même pas hors sujet je suis même
pas vaguement hors sujet avec ça donc ça
je vais pas en parler
voilà j'en ai déjà trop parlé c'est
c'est un problème qui est résolue depuis
longtemps le crâne de roundup lui m'a
donné du fil à retordre donc celui là on
va en parler un petit peu plus loin dans
la vidéo le crâne de sealand qui est un
exemple de quelque chose dont je ne vais
pas parler qui sont les faut absolument
évident parce que là ce crâne de seeland
il est en plastique ça se voit donc on
voit là tout ce qui est crâne faut en
plastoc ou photoshopée ça je vais pas en
parler parce que évidemment c'est un peu
trop faciles à débusquer je veux dire
regardez celui là ça se voit qu'il est
faux de dire s'il n'ya même pas une
seule seconde où on importe qui a pu
croire que ce truc là était vrai quoi je
veux dire même ne serait-ce que les
dents elles sont trop parfaite quoi les
dents sont beaucoup trop parfaite donc
ça c'est du faux voilà il ya des
exemples de mauvaise foi affligeante
comme le crâne de bison préhistorique
que vous avez en face de vous alors
c'est un bison préhistorique avec un
trou de balle de fusil et ça on nous
prétend que c'est inexpliqué alors je
vais peut-être avoir l'air d'un trou du
cul condescendant en disant ça mais pour
faire un crâne de bison préhistorique
avec un trou de balle de fusil
il suffit de prendre un crâne de bison
préhistorique de le poser par terre de
prendre un fusil et de tirer et là
encore je pars du principe qu'il s'agit
effectivement d'un trou de balle de
fusil et pas juste d'un trou dans le
crâne comme ça quoi donc
non là c'est juste de la mauvaise foi
les scientifiques peuvent expliquer
comment on fait un crâne de bison avec
un trou de balle de fusil dedans il
suffit d'un crâne de bison préhistorique
et d'un fusil
donc non il n'ya rien d'inexplicable et
les crânes extraterrestre russe que pour
ma part j'appellerai les crânes
extraterrestre nazi parce qu'ils ont été
trouvés dans un petit coffret qui a été
caché par les nazis il ya toute une
histoire derrière mais je vais pas trop
m'intéresser au contexte mois ce qui va
m'intéresser c'est vraiment les crânes
mais moi je les appellerai pas les
crânes russe parce que j'ai un autre
crâne rue sans réserve il n'y a pas que
les crânes qui sont sur ce site dont je
vais parler
donc j'ai un autre crâne rue sans
réserve cela je vais les appeler les
crânes nazis voilà et puis parce que les
nazis ça fait toujours des vues sur
youtube et j'ai envie de faire du pit à
cliquer en ce moment voilà donc on
retourne à notre petite présentation sur
fond noir et on va commencer par
justement le crâne le mystérieux crâne
de russie dont je vous parlais pour vous
parler des deux grands principes que je
vais appliquer aujourd'hui le premier
grand principe quand il s'agit
d'identifier des crânes mystérieux c'est
de savoir de comprendre que deux trous
symétrique sur un crâne ça fait pas
forcément des yeux donc on appelle ça
une pareille de ligue 1 donc voici par
exemple le fameux crâne mystérieux de
russie dont je vous parlais donc il
s'agit d'un crâne qui a circulé voilà
une photo de crâne qui a circulé sur
internet comme étant celui d'un crâne
mystérieux et donc et donc on y
identifie assez aisément deux yeux une
sorte de néo est une sorte de bouche de
ce qui lui donne un air assez bedie que
vous pourrez le constater
alors je conteste pas le fait qu'il
s'agit d'un vrai crâne
c'est un véritable crâne il n'y a pas de
faux derrière ça comme je vous ai dit
j'exclus tous les faux par contre je
conteste le fait que ces deux trous que
vous voyez là ce sont les yeux en
réalité si on superpose un crâne de
cheval par dessus ça eh bien vous
constatez que il s'agit en fait du
dessous et de l'arrière d'un crâne de
cheval donc en l'occurrence on identifie
très très bien certaines structures
anatomiques comme les deux condyle
occipitaux c'est à dire les points
d'articulation du crâne avec la colonne
vertébrale
on identifie très bien les deux sinus
périllaud ti
donc qui accueille l'os qui contient
l'oreille interne
quand le crâne quand le cheval est
vivant mais là apparemment ces eaux sont
tombés sur ce crâne qui est très abîmé
le dire vous pouvez même voir qu'à
l'avant justement est bien le crâne a
été cassée puisque la boîte crânienne
est exposé et on voit à l'intérieur de
cette bras de cette boîte crânienne les
petites circonvolutions qui sont
finalement l'empreinte du cerveau sur
l'os donc il ne s'agit que d'un crâne de
cheval est ce qu'on croyait être des
yeux étaient en fait des sinus périllaud
tic et si on fait attention aux détails
eh ben on remarque qu'il ne s'agit ni
plus ni moins que d'une structure
anatomique connu depuis longtemps sur
des animaux très ordinaire et cela
m'amène à mon deuxième point on va
parler de la pneumatique à sion du crâne
alors je vous parlais des animaux
ordinaire et bien les animaux les plus
ordinaires que nous connaissons ce sont
les animaux les grands herbivores
domestique ce sont les vaches les
chevaux les moutons pourquoi c'est d'eux
dont on va parler aujourd'hui est bien
parce que comme ils sont herbivores ils
sont extrêmement nombreux les herbivores
sont incroyablement plus nombreux que
les carnivores dans le règne animal et
donc c'est leur crâne qu'on va avoir le
plus de chances de retrouver quand on se
promène comme ça et ils ont cette
particularité tous ces grands herbivores
d'avoir une pneumatiques à sion
importante du crâne
ce qui fait que dès qu'ils s'usent dès
qu on les casse un peu eh bien ils
commencent à avoir des têtes un peu pas
possible donc ici vous voyez le crâne
d'une vache sur la gauche et vous pouvez
voir que ce crâne de vaches et bien il
est en fait il ya une couche de creux
entre la boîte crânienne et sa surface
et cette couche de creux elle envahit
même les cornes ce qui fait que même les
cornes sont creuses chez les vaches et
les moutons par exemple donc ça déjà bas
c'est un peu c'est un peu à what the
fuck quoi les cornes sont en fait creuse
chez les vaches et les moutons et du
coup ça rende difficile l'identification
de certains crânes extrêmement usées et
on va voir que par exemple ici les
crânes nazis typiquement ce sont en fait
des arrières crâne d'un mouton ou d'une
chèvre et dont les dont on peut voir une
cassure qui expose l'intérieur des
cornes qui est creux donc là je vous
montre sur la vidéo comment on passe
justement de là
ces crânes à un crâne de moutons et il
suffit finalement de percer deux trous à
la base des cornes pour exposer le sinus
c'est qui remplit ses cornes
du coup et qu'on appelle le sinus parra
nasale d'ailleurs si vous voulez des
termes scientifiques pour décrire pour
décrire le nom de ce sinus et bien le
sinus qui occupe tout le tout le crâne
chez les herbivores on l'appelle le ciri
le sinus parra nasal et là où ça devient
très intéressant avec ses fameux crâne
nazis c'est que si vous avez du mal à
croire qu'il s'agit en fait de crâne de
mouton ou de crâne de chèvre et bien il
y à des radiographies qui ont été faites
de ces crânes et l'une d'entre elle
exposé très clairement ce qu'on peut
reconnaître comme étant la boîte
crânienne et l'intérieur creux des deux
cornes que je vous compare ici à une
radio du mouflon donc tout à l'heure je
vous ai fait défiler une petite
animation d'un mouflon qui passait qui
était radiographier enfin qui a été cité
scanner en réalité c'est de la
tomographie à rayons x mais c'est à peu
près le même principe
c'est juste en 3d c'est tout mais au
final ça vous donne des radiographies et
sur ses radiographies et bien si on fait
un arrêt sur images on peut voir les
mêmes structures que sur les crânes
nazis donc ces crânes nazis ne sont ni
plus ni moins que des crânes de chèvres
de moutons seront enfin un crâne d'ovins
quelconque un peu dur à identifier dans
cet état là évidemment mais voilà c'est
rien c'est rien d'extrêmement exotiques
et si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincu
bas voici l'arrière d'un crâne de
mouflons et voici le l'un de ces crânes
nazis prix selon une vue assez similaire
donc ces crânes de mouflons en termes
scientifiques on appelle ça une grosse
connerie
alors notre deuxième crâne aujourd'hui
ça va être ce que j'appelle le crâne
chinois bon pourquoi le crâne chinois
parce qu'il a été découvert par un
ufologue chinois et donc c'est du faux
locke chinois clame que ce crâne
mystérieux et celui évidemment d'un
alien alors ce qui est marrant avec ce
crâne c'est qu'il a un côté concave un
côté tout plat et entre les deux vous
pouvez voir la pneumatique à sion voilà
deux dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
donc là quand vous voyez cette
pneumopathie dation là c'est toutes ces
cavités à l'intérieur de ce crâne tout
de suite normalement maintenant que vous
savez que
que les herbivores ont ce genre de
pneumatiques à sion ça doit tout de
suite vous mettre la puce à l'oreille
et effectivement quand on compare ce
crâne à un crâne de bovins que je
m'apprête à retourner sur cette petite
animation et bien on constate assez
rapidement que la concavité sur le
dessus correspond en réalité à
l'empreinte du cerveau à l'intérieur de
la boîte crânienne donc en fait cette
concavité ce n'est pas le haut du crâne
d'un crâne inconnu c'est en fait le
dessus de la boîte crânienne avec
l'empreinte des deux hémisphères
cérébraux dessus et on voit très bien
les pneus l'apno matiz à sion du crâne
sur la tranche du crâne de bovins qui se
compare extrêmement bien à celle sur le
crâne chinois hélas ce qui est
intéressant à noter c'est la surface
creuse avec toutes ces circonvolutions
qu'on peut voir en fait il s'agit de
l'empreinte des deux hémisphères à
l'intérieur de la boîte crânienne et
vous voyez toutes ces circonvolutions en
fait ce sont les empreintes des
circonvolutions du cerveau donc ça c'est
un très fort indicateur de ce qu'on est
en train de regarder parce que ce qu'il
ya de très forts avec ses crânes
mystérieux souvent c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas orientés
voilà comme par exemple le crâne chinois
ici il n'est pas du tout orienté comme
il faut sur cette photo comparé à ce
crâne de bovins donc l'orientation c'est
quelque chose qui est pas facile à faire
donc à partir du moment où vous vous
avez localiser les sinus ça vous permet
de localiser le haut du crâne parce que
le sinus parent nasale il est toujours
sur le haut du crâne donc en fait ce
crâne chinois là il a été pris en photo
à l'envers ce que vous voyez sur cette
photo en fait c'est le dessous du
spécimen et le dessus en fait il est
tout plat donc la simple connaissance du
fait qu'il y a ceux sinus parent nasale
vous permet tout de suite d'orienter les
spécimens et ensuite si vous savez que
en dessous du sinus parent nasale on a
une bonne chance de trouver l'empreinte
du cerveau sur la boîte crânienne
bah ça vous permet d'être encore plus
sûr de ce que vous êtes en train de
regarder et de dents et dans quel sens
vous est essentielle prendre surtout
chose que visiblement notre ufologues
chinois n'a pas fait donc ici vu sur une
photo maintenant donc on laisse tomber
un peu l'animation mais comparé à une
photo d'un crâne de bovins qui a été
coupée d'avant en arrière en fait
horizontalement d'avant en arrière et
bien le crâne chinois en fait se
placerait ici voilà donc la
correspondance est assez évidente entre
les deux ça se superposent très très
bien donc ce crâne chinois et bien ce
n'est pas plus un crâne mystérieux que
ça donc appeler ça un crâne mystérieux
encore une fois un terme scientifique on
appelle ça une grosse connerie le crâne
suivant est celui qui m'a donné le plus
de fil à retordre
il s'agit du crâne d'euros d'offres et
celui là pour le coup il est
effectivement assez difficile à analyser
parce que j'ai pas trouvé tout de suite
ce que c'était là celui-là il m'a
vraiment fait réfléchir alors encore une
fois si on le regarde on voit que le
dessus et plat et que en dessous on a
des sinus donc il a été assez facile
tout de suite de me rendre compte que ce
petit bout de sinus parana dallas a
pointé tout droit vers un herbivore
certainement un beau vin mais ça n'a pas
été facile de trouver à quel genre de
bovins ça appartenait et au final j'ai
fini par trouver quand même un crâne de
bovins je crois que ça doit être un
crâne de vache mais je suis pas sûr
qu'ils étaient cassés plus ou moins de
la même façon et qui permet de voir
exactement ce que le crâne de rawdon est
en réalité
alors voici le crâne de bovins un très
identifiable à ces corps non
il n'y a pas de doute sur le fait que ce
crâne appartient une vache ou à quelque
chose de très très proches
déjà je vais vous montrer la structure
qui m'a donné la puce à l'oreille pour
identifier qu'il s'agissait d'un crâne
de bovins c'est cette petite crête ici
donc cette petite crainte on la retrouve
sur le crâne de roundup et samassa m'a
permis de voir qu'il s'agissait de la
base d'un crâne et à partir de là du
coup j'ai pu retrouver ce spécimen donc
qui nous montre bien la surface du crâne
que je vous montre ici avec le doigt le
sinus parra nasale juste en dessous
qu'on retrouve sur le crâne d'euros dope
ses deux trous là qui sont en fait les
deux trous pour les bulbeuses olfactive
du cerveau est en dessous les deux trous
pour ce qu'on appelle le foramen retombe
d'hommes qui est donc un passage de
nerfs et là vous avez ce côté là et ce
côté là qui ont été complètement de
casser en fait ils ne sont pas préservés
sur le crâne d'euros d'offres ce qui lui
donne cet aspect un peu triangulaire
mais sinon vous pouvez voir que toutes
les structures sont là
donc si on veut transformer ce crâne de
bovins au crâne d'europe
c'est pas compliqué il suffit de
découper en fait ce crâne sur les deux
côtés et comme ça on enlève les cornes
on enlève les deux petits morceaux que
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure avec le
doigt et on obtient finalement la même
structure avec le dessus qui est plat
les la pneumatique à sion en dessous les
deux trous pour les lieux au golf actifs
et les deux foramen rotonde homme qui se
trouve en dessous
et voilà vous avez créé votre crâne de
rodolphe donc ce crâne de roundup
il a finalement rien de mystérieux comme
tous les autres il s'agit ni plus ni
moins que d'un crâne de grands
herbivores un crâne de bovins dans ce
cas là qui a été cassé et dont on ne
voit plus les cornes et dont on voit
difficilement les structures est alors
dans tout le panel de photographies qui
a été fait du crâne de roundup
je vais m'intéresser aussi à cette photo
là il s'agit d'une photo du crâne de
rodolphe vu du dessous et encore une
fois si on compare cette vu du dessous
du crâne d'euros dope à notre crâne de
bovins coupé en deux dans le sens
horizontal et bien on peut leur place
est assez aisément exactement au même
endroit finalement que le crâne chinois
il s'agit de la boîte crânienne
ni plus ni moins à l'intérieur de
laquelle on voit justement l'impression
les impressions du cerveau sur la
surface de la
être crânienne donc ce crâne d'europe
idem il a rien de particulièrement
mystérieux il ne s'agit encore une fois
que d'un crâne d'un grand herbivore
en conclusion est ce que la somme est ce
que la science veut et peut expliquer
tous ces crânes mystérieux la réponse
est oui
la réponse est tout à fait oui il s'agit
tous deux crânes d'herbivores comment on
le sait grâce à la fnaut matiz à sion et
ensuite eh bien il suffit de trouver
quelques de quelle espèce il s'agit
alors je prétends pas avoir identifié
les espèces je pense qu'il s'agit de
bovins ou ovins ou d'autres grands
herbivores
mais évidemment c'est assez dur de
déterminer l'espèce avec des restes
aussi fragmentaire le crâne chinois en
particulier à une teinte et une patine
qui me fait même pensé à un fossile donc
il est même pas impossible que ce crâne
chinoises appartiennent à une espèce
éteinte en réalité et dans ce cas-là ça
rend le fait qu'un ufologues le garde
pour lui encore plus criminel mais
passons là dessus en tout cas ce qu'il
ya de sûr c'est que l'incapacité des
arcs et oman des pyramides you et des
ufologues à vouloir entendre ou
comprendre les explications
scientifiques ne constituera jamais en
rien une preuve que la science ne
s'intéresse pas à leur découverte
la science peut s'intéresser à leur
découverte mais s'ils sont pas prêts à
entendre ce qu'on a à leur dire
il est très clair qu'ils n'iront nulle
part et j'attends dans les commentaires
des réactions qui vont être des
réactions extrêmement rageuse de ces
gens là qui ne vont pas vouloir entendre
les explications j'ai à fournir mais
c'est pas parce que eux ne veulent pas
entendre mes explications que je n'ai
pas d'explication donc la science veut
et la science peut énoncer crâne ne
remet rien en question aucune théorie
officielle entre guillemets donc
finalement les seuls crâne mystérieux
baas et ceux qui contiennent un cerveau
qui croient encore que les scientifiques
ne s'intéresse pas à ces mystères et de
toute façon la seule raison pour
laquelle les scientifiques passent peu
de temps à étudier ces mystères bas
c'est juste parce qu'il s'agit pas de
mystère du tout voilà le crâne de rhodes
hop ça m'a pris une grosse demi-heure
pour comprendre ce que c'était voilà
donc s'il avait juste envoyé la photo du
crâne d'euros dope à un spécialiste et
qu'ils avaient su écouter ce que ce
spécialiste avait à dire et basse et
crâne il n'aurait pas été mystérieux
du tout donc mesdames et messieurs je
vous invite à attraper les crânes des
pyramides you des arcs et oman et des
ufologues qui ne veulent pas entendre ce
qu'on a à leur dire et de coller votre
oreille dessus et vous verrez on entend
l'océan
voilà merci à tous et à la prochaine
fois sur stop science
[Musique]